what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel it's live shoot
today i am going to be reacting to evan
preach um why the f of my single bro
attractive woman loses it before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell that
way you're going to be notified of my
daily videos um
please i'm trying to get to um 19 000
subscribers
before i go to england i think that
would be a dope goal so hit the
subscribe button
only if you like my content if you don't
you know
you don't gotta
okay i'ma start today's topic somebody
sent me this tick tock video
my question is why are these beautiful
woman single bro
why the [ __ ] am i single bro why the
[ __ ] am i single guys because you said
bro five times already next video
but you don't find that why the [ __ ] bro
bro
bro why the
one look at this bro what what the [ __ ]
bro
no
no you know about that bro life bro
you said bro five times already you know
what i would expect if you turned off
the lights okay and if i couldn't see
you
and i was just hearing this i'd be like
why the [ __ ] am i single bro
bro
bro
why the [ __ ] am i single bro bro
bro why the [ __ ] am i single bro
bro
why the [ __ ] am i single bro bro
bro that's what i would expect kind of
energy but you know what
everyone's built different
it's just when you talk you say bro and
you taste yourself too much
yeah
like
bro
like but maybe it's just a cultural
thing maybe
latino don't think it i don't even know
if it's latin it sounds very italian or
no this is tex-mex this is tex-mex yeah
never mind and carry on yeah american
too i've been single
i'm gonna be single my god i'm gonna be
single
for four [ __ ] years now oh wow in a
few months [ __ ] i haven't had a
boyfriend like officially no dude and i
just think about it and i look at myself
and i'm like [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] pretty [ __ ] like i'm not
trying to sound like you know i'm an
egoistic or whatever but like dude i'm
pretty a [ __ ]
i gotta ass
[ __ ] i got my own place i make my own
okay i could literally tell you
like three reasons she's single okay
guys don't like when they're looking for
a wife or a girlfriend they don't like
the fake nails they don't like the caked
on makeup the fake eyelashes and they
don't like
this long
fake hair
they really prefer you to just like rock
what you got probably more makeup than i
do personally like
you know like light makeup but guys
don't like
just
like all the
fake stuff i cook i clean
maybe you're bad [ __ ] crazy
maybe there's some guys that i know that
are single
they're bad [ __ ] crazy
that's why
americans say they like they lack
self-awareness
you can't have all the package the abs
and everything
you're crazy you crazy
and i'm gonna tell you this it's gonna
be even worse for ladies
there are more ladies than men
more
some of y'all gonna be single
on both sides but if we look at the
numbers not everybody's going to find
that somebody
not everybody
i got i have a friend
she told me she said that shout out uh
claudia she said
i think i'm not my types type
think about it i think i'm not my types
type there's that the guys i want i'm
probably not their type so there's that
there's
maybe you're bad [ __ ]
maybe you're annoying maybe a lot of
things maybe a lot of things or maybe
your boyfriend doesn't want you to
you can't call him a boyfriend because
it's not the guy that you're you know
maybe the guy that you're with you know
your boyfriend doesn't want you to call
him bro
to you stuart
i have nothing to add back when i was 19
i was dating this girl and we were
dating we seen each other for like three
four months and uh
i was like yeah yeah you might hold me
and she's excuse me
i was like yo what up hold me what's
wrong yeah i caught my friends homie
though yeah but i was dating her oh yeah
yeah you like excuse me i was like
what's wrong i'm sick
don't call me homie i was like that's a
tear of endearment nah it's like i call
my mom homie too say i'm not your mom
i'm like [ __ ] this is not getting any
better
but i call the people like my brothers
i would not
no
homie no
no that's not your brother i we [ __ ]
and i was like
okay homie
[Music]
like
i got long hair i don't like i got long
hair i got a it's fake that's there's no
way that hair is booty i look cute i
look good okay pero like i don't even
understand why these guys they don't
want to date me like bro i don't
understand bro
i kind of do
i kind of do
i got a good personality i'm funny
sometimes i got an attitude but i'm not
like
sometimes i got crazy attitude but i'm
not crazy me you know
[ __ ] that say sometimes i got an
attitude literally
always
they're always crazy they might say
i'm a lot thanks for putting up with me
like that just means i i'm angry and i
don't know how to control it that you're
crazy and you got an attitude that's
what it means that's what it means
nobody's gonna be like yeah i'm you know
what yeah i'm
i'm crazy that's why i need to tone if
sometimes i get a little physical but
i'm not abusive you know what i'm saying
like sometimes i put my hands on him but
it's not like violent violent
bro
is it that hard like is it that a hard
finding of like a good genuine person
[ __ ] bro am i gonna be single forever
no mames
guys guys
i'm kind of freaking out
like is it that [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
anyways i'm gonna go cry that's great
that's great video
it's great content maybe she's not even
single she's doing that you know likes
and [ __ ] but
i don't know i don't know you okay dog
that [ __ ] that we said was really just
for comedy right i was not
i was not
believing none of that i don't know you
i don't know you hate what yeah this
but it might be your personality
and everything about
about you that's keeping you single if
you're single
you're the common denominator of all
that single thing you know i mean
there's a lot of things that could
happen be and there's a lot of reason
why you could be single a lot of things
this is the female version of the
supreme gentleman okay remember that
dude who went up to that school and shot
up everyone but he did that video just
before where he's like
i have my own car look at these shades
these are three thousand dollar shades
i'm a gentleman the way i treat women
i'm such a kind man
and these women they just
they act like i'm invisible
well you're gonna see me today [ __ ] and
then he went up and shot up the whole
school oh
yeah he called himself the supreme
gentleman
isn't this a female i don't understand
well i'm not desire it's just the other
end of that spectrum
this is the other end of that spectrum
and here's the truth you know oftentimes
ladies who are attractive and have these
struggles most of the time it's just
they don't find guys that they find
attractive enough to be with them
there's plenty of dudes who line up but
they just don't mean to look standard or
they're not tall enough or they're not
this enough and you know sometimes when
people say they can't find me what
they're really saying is consider them i
don't want to settle that's what they're
saying my really high standards i can't
find someone who meets them and you know
do i feel bad for people
no
no
all the people that you want that one
person that you want there's a lot of
y'all [ __ ] fighting for that
and you got to be
something very specific and special to
get that
or not
you just got just gotta know like i said
everyone learns to settle for things in
life and if you don't want to that's
fine keep rolling them dies
watch the tears go by and after that
if you don't and you still find someone
well you played the game and you're lost
and it's okay
but not everyone deserves somebody who
meets their standards especially if your
standards aren't reasonable that's
pretty much all i have
anything else you would like to say to
the young lady
bro
[Laughter]
i'm not even gonna front you like it's a
girl comes on some like hella masculine
energy talking about yo what up bro
yeah no that's pretty nasty it's like
you know what the thing is like if
someone sent me a meme like that but
it's it's kind of true it was kind of
funny he's like yo i want i'm sorry i
just can we have feminine women back
could you i wanna have i wanna i'm sick
and tired of those genuine soldiers and
i was like
there's some girls sometimes they come
up to you like yo man what up dude you
look my cute like what all in the dress
and everything and stuff i'm like okay
this is like a side of girls that i see
as a former college athlete
you'll love girls that like behind
closed doors when the guys aren't around
are one way
and then the guys will come out
and it's like oh my god
like
like lady you were just screaming at me
on the court like five minutes ago what
what happened to that energy
anyways
sometimes the girls just hide it well
that's not but here's the thing i don't
want to hear yeah dude [ __ ] me hard i'm
like what if you rolled up on a girl
you're like man look at this feminine
[ __ ] yo come over here mom
you would she would definitely be like
huh
she would have been like huh yeah
exactly
you feminine ass [ __ ] come here
looking all buffy [ __ ] listen i know
you're talking about a girl but it
sounds gay exactly it sounds gay but
exactly for when the girl come in with
that yo what up you look my it's weird
it's the display is weird the bro this
the hands yeah don't don't you don't
don't come with that fat energy okay
unless you're lebanese or italian which
is pretty much the same thing you
shouldn't be yelling bro every five
seconds
okay
or greek fair but greek they don't say
bro no it's liberties in a time yeah
yeah
but if a girl comes to me it's like yo
ray
yo my bro come here you look good though
no it's going to be weird yeah it's
going to be weird looking these people
are pretty much italians with a bit of
like
like tzatziki sauce
greeks are are are italians with spinach
yes yes
little fed on top
a little bit of olive oil
but that motherfucker's saying bro a lot
yeah bro
it's really the bro is one level the red
is another level so my advice to you
ladies don't be out here talking to
every dude like bro
i'm not saying it's gonna stop you but
it's pretty nasty
it's just it's just it's not that
appealing and ladies you guys don't want
to be talked to like
most ladies don't want to be talked to
like that either
true all this to say don't follow my
example all right young lady i advise
you maybe not to to you say bro as much
or even curse as much it's uh
yeah but do you you know i mean live
your best life it's working anyways let
us know what you guys
think in the comments below okay
all right guys that's my reaction um
i agree you know if you're single
common denominator with you
should give you guys i should do a story
time from when i was single
i feel like
i feel like you guys would be
entertained anyways um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next